welcome to episode 79 of the michaela
peterson podcast in this episode i had
kelly brogan on this was one of my
favorite podcasts kelly is sharp she's a
psychiatrist now a holistic psychiatrist
author of the new york times bestselling
book a mind of your own own yourself the
children's book a time for reign and
co-editor of the landmark textbook
integrative therapies for depression if
you're suffering from depression or
mental illness or relationship problems
or emotional problems this episode is
really worth watching and taking
seriously
she's the founder of the online healing
program vital mind reset and the
membership community vital life project
she completed her psychiatric training
and fellowship at nyu medical center
after graduating from cornell university
medical college and has a bachelor of
science from mit
in systems neuroscience
she specializes in a root cause
resolution approach to psychiatric
syndromes and symptoms she's a
powerhouse
we spoke about psychiatry in
conventional western medicine and
alternative medicine super alternative
ssris messed me up they helped me
initially then ruined my life for a
number of years after i stopped taking
them so this is a topic very close to my
heart
if you enjoy these episodes please hit
subscribe this episode is brought to you
by superspeciosa a kratom company kratom
is a herb related to the coffee plant
the leaves or extracts from the leaves
have been used as a stimulant and a
sedative it works on opiate receptors in
the brain so it's been used to treat
chronic pain digestive ailments and aid
in withdrawal from opiate dependence
if you tried cbd and you felt like it
isn't quite what you're looking for or
even if you like cbd but you also want
to try something else kratom might be
for you there have also been reports of
kratom abuse but whenever you try
anything don't be stupid don't drink 12
cups of coffee a day or you'll get
withdrawal do your research and decide
drugs are drugs i myself occasionally
like kratom and think it can be
beneficial if used properly i've used it
as a substitute for coffee coffee
doesn't make me feel good or is an
overall calming tea some people use it
to manage stress and to help them relax
i know how hard this year has been and
is on people and something like kratom
tea is safer in my opinion than a
pharmaceutical it's very effective
superspeciosa has different strains some
help you relax some give you energy
whatever you're looking for they have
you covered this kratom is reliable
third lab tested and approved under the
american kratom association's quality
standards program
only natural kratom no other ingredients
visit
getsuperleaf.com
mp to buy small servings or in bulk
either way you'll be saving a lot of
money to get guaranteed high quality
kratom so if you want to try kratom you
can get 20 off by going to get super
leaf dot com mp enter code mp for 20 off
thanks super speciosa for the
sponsorship enjoy the episode
[Music]
dr kelly brogan welcome to my podcast
it's an honor
it's an honor for me i'm so excited to
talk to you i've known about you for a
while but
it's cool getting you on the podcast
so thank you i'm excited yes thank you
can we start off by you giving a brief
background about who you are and what it
is you do
yeah i guess so the most relevant and
interesting uh detail about my
sort of resume so to speak is that i
have had many many a rebirth right so
i'm probably on like my eighth
personality in this lifetime
and i was very very much uh kind of died
in the wool
believer in what i now refer to as the
church of scientism
but what was previously referred to in
my life as conventional medicine and i
became interested in becoming a
allopathic doctor when i was at mit
for undergrad and i was working a
suicide hotline actually called
nightline
and suicide is a completed suicide
actually is a big issue
at mit probably still is this was some
time ago obviously but
i became
really inspired and convinced that we
had cracked the code of human behavior
and human suffering and that psychiatry
and associated medications held the
answer and so we just needed to connect
those who are suffering to the system
that would help them
and i was supervised by this
grandfatherly psychiatrist and i thought
wow i really want to
do good in the world through this field
and so i went to medical school you know
with that intent
and i specialized in a burgeoning field
at the time
called reproductive psychiatry which is
the believe it or not medicating with
psychotropics of pregnant and
breastfeeding women i was one of the
first 300 in the world
as as you know what ultimately was
emerging at the time was the fact that
one in four women were on
psychotropic medications going into
pregnancies or considering pregnancy or
unexpectedly you know pregnant
and we didn't have the data to help them
make any sort of informed
decision
and so there were a group of dedicated
uh psychiatrists who were really
focusing mostly on what's called
registry data which is the passive
collection of
outcomes by the pharmaceutical companies
themselves to
kind of inform whether or not there are
any major red flags or major signals of
harm
and so i spent some time you know
trying to help women navigate whether to
continue medication start them
discontinue them but the only so-called
alternative was just not taking your
meds right there wasn't this concept
that there's anything else to do
with symptoms other than you know
psychotherapy medication or just kind of
like white knuckle it
and so it really wasn't until i was uh
pregnant myself postpartum
and diagnosed with my first health
condition and prior to that i had been
very kind of disembodied like i just
wasn't in this vessel and
i've
always been i guess kind of like
naturally on the thin side so i could
eat mcdonald's
five to seven times a week in white
castle and popeyes and candy all day
long and never exercise and you know
take birth control and it just
wasn't a thing i thought i was like an
irritable tired person and that was kind
of it you know and when i was diagnosed
with something called hashimoto's
thyroiditis
i just didn't want to take a
prescription for the rest of my life it
was really a matter of convenience but i
knew that there was no other way you
know that the conventional system had to
offer me and so
i went to a naturopath which is so funny
to me now because i was very disparaging
as you are you know when you are
dogmatic
of
you know so-called alternative medicine
and
i went to this you know very brilliant
naturopath in new york city and she
helped me to
adjust my diet
and i took a bunch of supplements and i
saw on paper which is what i needed the
way my mind works i needed that proof i
still do
uh and i saw on paper you know my
antibody levels you know go from the
high 2000s to normal range and my
something called tsh you know normalize
and instead of feeling
you know
so excited and wow i just you know put
this into remission
i was
enraged something ignited in me that was
i'm still working on i'm still working
on 11 years later and i i it's like i
took my sword out of my sheath and i was
i ran naked onto battlefield and i spent
years um
very angry you can even if if you've
read my first book you can feel it
you know i had a an amazing co-writer
who helped polish me up a little bit but
you can feel it i felt
the betrayal you know that a child feels
when they see that their
their parent
you know injured them or harmed them or
maybe didn't have their best interest at
heart in a moment
and
i i thought that very adolescent
uh fight for some years against the
pharmaceutical industry as a whole at
the time i had also read a book called
anatomy of an epidemic
and uh by robert whittaker and who's an
intrepid investigative journalist yeah
and uh yeah you know him and uh yeah
i never prescribed the medication again
after i turned the last page
i
i committed uh it wasn't even an effort
actually
my entire practice for the ensuing you
know 11 some years to helping patients
come off of medication
and so i have you know more experience
than most the world over because i have
never restarted someone on medication i
have never initiated a medication since
that time so i've come to really see
what
the dark night of the soul you know that
is induced by these medication
withdrawal experiences and and even very
strategically engaged tapers uh what it
can really look like on a
psycho-spiritual level but also on a
physiologic level because i've said many
times that i believe
uh psychotropic medications to be the
most habit-forming chemicals on earth
and there's something very very powerful
as you know um
that is engaged when you when you take
that first
that first potion uh to your lips and
so you know since that time i've done a
lot of personal spiritual work on
transforming that rage and aggression
and anger and righteousness
my shadow really and i have
spent probably the past
three or so years but largely since
meeting my now husband sayer um really
trying to come into
you know that complementary energy that
feminine energy and embody and really uh
come into balance as you know a mother
and
uh someone who has you know
a heart to share as well i guess
okay uh part of the reason i wanted to
have you on is because i've had
i it wasn't exactly a similar experience
but
when i found out that
like when i put myself into remission
without the medical system like i'm
still so angry about it that it almost
like
so
i've been trying to work through that
and i'm not as angry as i was like um i
used to have panic attacks going into
hospitals i talked about this on a
previous episode but it wasn't even
something it wasn't something i meant to
do it's as soon as i put myself into
remission i i had panic attacks going
into hospitals and my dad was like
that's a reasonable response given what
happened yes
yeah but still not super convenient if i
ever like break a bone and need surgery
um which is you know you know might
happen um but
yeah so i think we should talk a little
bit about
turning especially as a woman turning
that like anger and rage and
also ability
to be extremely competent in research
not to like toot my own horn or anything
but i mean you're smart obviously you
went to mit
then you figured out that medical
community isn't exactly what everybody
thinks it is which is
an insane discovery right
and turning that into some sort of
feminine
spirit or power or something
i think we should touch on that a little
bit because
mostly i just want to hear what you have
to say for me but i'm sure somebody
listening is also going to take some
lesson away from it yeah i know it's you
it's relevant
it's relevant to all of us right now um
in this current moment and
i've come to see
the
sort of awareness generating experiences
that we sometimes bring to ourselves
like you mentioned being a researcher
right a citizen researcher and i've come
to see
these
um
you know sort of journeys as being
largely driven by our relationship to
our own personal and specifically
childhood trauma because i've come at it
through
the intellectual informational angle you
know when i uh started to research all
pharmaceuticals that i had ever thought
were sacred cows and that includes birth
control i was taking that includes all
of the psychotropics i was prescribing
that includes antibiotics of course i've
taken plenty of in my life
that includes vaccines which i was in a
position to have to decide around as a
new mother
uh
i
you know am very adept at for whatever
reason related to my intellectual
defense defenses i'm very adept at
understanding reading and translating
scientific medical literature and so i
would collect all of these references
you know hundreds and hundreds of them
in my blogs and in my books and whatever
and i would do presentations and
keynotes and all this stuff around the
world
and honestly i'm not sure i have ever
changed someone's mind
that way yeah ever not like literally
not one person ever and i'm a decent
debater too you know so i don't i'm not
afraid um you know to run my run my
mouth
and that really stumped me because you
know when my first book came out which
was blacklisted uh by mainstream media
despite having gotten a very uh generous
advance in being the feature book at
hartford collins in its you know publish
publishing season
i thought well anyone who reads this
will never touch a medication again done
case closed you know i've made the point
there's a better way
and obviously that did not happen which
is why i wrote a second book largely
about
what it is that drives our
devotional trust
in a system that has never once
demonstrated that it has our well-being
in mind nor that it defines health
in the same way that we do right most
most know that the conventional system
is terrified of death right this is an
existential issue that has been codified
into an entire system that is now
dominating the world orthodoxy you know
around this concept of health being just
the absence of death
uh and
that's not what we experience health as
right we experience health as this very
complex dynamic uh vitalism right which
is more a chiropractor you know sort of
concept they've been championing that
for for decades
so i've really come to understand this
developmental
maturational arc that is
the human journey
right
that requires a very important element
which is initiation
to self
and in our country i'll just speak for
americans
we have no relationship to that
whatsoever right we don't know what it
is to transition from dependency on our
parents and our parents worldview and
navigating around that worldview whether
we reject it fiercely which is what
you're doing what i've done right that
rejection is
is still
you know kind of circumnavigating
the authority of the parent
sovereignty doesn't look like that
adultification doesn't look like that
individuation doesn't look like that so
how do you transition from either
complying or defying
with your parents or a projected
authority whether that's the medical
system the doctor or the teacher or the
principal of the school whatever it is
your boss
how do you transition from
you know that dependent patterning of
relating to authority through these
vectors
into self-possession
into an understanding of who you are and
that your essential self
doesn't need anything else in the world
to change in order for you to be okay
right how do you access that spine
and still have your heart soft and open
that normally is done indigenously
traditionally through some sort of
initiation ritual that is held by you
know the community at large where you're
reflected that when you think you're
about to die right so let's say it's a
vision quest or something like that
you don't
you don't die
and you come into contact with that
deeper ground of being
that will then support you as you
understand who it is that you actually
are independent of those influences and
conditioning and programming
of your
family of origin so this should happen
in our teen years
right but instead we have this extended
childhood that takes us through college
where we you know we don't have any
understanding of who it is that we are
and we are constantly following orders
encouraged to be obedient and compliant
and largely confined to a very very
small box of critical thought
right so my daughter is 12 she's not in
school she has a very well paying job
she runs a business natural business
she's written a movie script she's
published poetry and you know the list
goes on and on and on because
she can do all those things as a 12 year
old but culturally we have been
convinced that you have to wait till
you're like 26 to begin to start to do
things you know on your own
and this infantilization is actually in
my opinion
because i'm an arch conspiracy theorist
you must know
is by design it's strategic to keep us
dependent and in an experience of
illusory helplessness out of touch with
our own power
so like
my advice
would be
you know
look at
what's got the heat in your life right
like what can get your
your heart racing what can get you
sweating what can get you like super
angry
you know in 30 seconds
and
you know for me that's like so many
aspects of the control grid the
government et cetera medical system
and recognize that
there is a projection happening there
right of the bad daddy or the bad mommy
right and as long as you fight that bad
mommy you feel powerful you hold the
good and you project the bad
but the true
you know experience of our power is in
understanding the mix what psychology is
called a mixed object
right so this concept
of you know i we all have it all right
so at the beginning of this process in
the past year
i took a long hard look
at the ways in which i might be
exhibiting the behaviors that i was
condemning
you know on the part of our ruling elite
and authority figures right so how and
where
is
is kelly you know engaging in
totalitarian
you know dogmatic thinking how am i
living in hierarchical energy
right so i stepped down as ceo of my own
company uh actually at the end of
december
and i'm now in a partnership model with
my team which to me was a gesture
to the universe to myself to them
of i am
not the leader right i am not the
authority we are all co-creating this
together because i knew that otherwise i
would be consistently projecting those
parts of myself
onto more convenient entities to judge
than myself right so then i don't have
to look at how i am that too
right and whenever you hear so you see
someone pointing a finger judging or
whatever
invariably they are exhibiting exactly
that which they
judge
that's that's inevitable right so how do
we reclaim those aspects of ourselves we
take radical responsibility
oh my cat's about to walk across the
computer sorry we take radical
responsibility
right
because we are adults
and victim consciousness belongs in the
the child space
right so when we take radical
responsibility
we own
our response
no one
can hurt
me but me no one
and that is not a popular concept and
that's why i've been criticized for
shaming victims and all this stuff which
is part of of course the machinery of
keeping people victimized dependent and
helpless
you know mental illness destigmatization
campaigns and
oh poor you with your depression take
your meds you know that's a
international agenda at this point
and it feels good for a moment to be
validated for our suffering because we
are suffering right and and we are
struggling and we are confused and we
are disconnected but it's like this very
you know transitory uh validation
because ultimately what you then need is
a consistence called often like
narcissistic supply like consistent
you know energy of validation of your
victimhood
all around you
everyone's got to acknowledge
how how hard it is for you how unfair it
is for you right and we all do this we
all do it we complain and we have a
complaining culture
but when you take responsibility
there's no more blaming there's no more
finger pointing there's no more
victimhood everything fundamentally
makes sense to you that is happening
because it's through the lens of your
creative power right so you come into a
reclamation of the fact that you've
always had this world creating power and
you've been told you don't and you need
these authorities to help you safely
navigate the dangerous random world you
know that we live in and the truth is
that we
exp sorry it's like very very intrusive
today
always
and the truth is that you know
when we shift even neurobiologically
when we shift out of helplessness and
dependency and into
self-possession
all sorts of so-called miracles happen
you know which is why i've been able to
publish you know many many case reports
case series and even a randomized trial
demonstrating that you don't need a
doctor uh and you yourself can heal
in a short period of time
from so-called chronic recidivistic and
even incurable illnesses
those miracles happen simply because
there is a shift a transfer of the seat
of power to the self from the external
world
and this can you know this can happen
for any of us if we just start to take
responsibility for our daily choices for
our own self-care and for our thought
forms that we are engaging and we start
to understand dyadic dynamics and
relationships that we are in as always
mirroring
you know that which we might not
otherwise want to look at about
ourselves you know so because i believe
that victimhood and victim consciousness
is the only human pathology and once we
learn to transform that and step into
really an adult consciousness which is
far more complex and nuanced and far
more empowering
then we we break free it's like a spell
we're under we break free of so much
conditioning i mean nearly
instantaneously
that that was great
i want that as the clip just putting
that in there uh
okay so when i i had my i guess
transformation i don't know what to call
it because i'm pretty new to
this way of thinking
but when i was
like 22 and i was so sick like i was
really dying my skin wasn't healing and
i was like i can't get help here i can't
get any help here i have to do it myself
and then i did it myself and it took me
i'd been like pittering pitter-pattering
around in research for the previous like
four years but i went like all in and it
took me eight months to put myself into
remission
from like joint replacement arthritis
and like bipolar and my skin not healing
it took me eight months
and i was like
what the hell is this and that's when it
was just like i saw just like some sort
of haze fell away and i was just like
horrified for
still
but uh
yeah i i do like that that you take the
power out of the external world and then
it
starts growing in yourself or you find
it there
that's i mean yeah it's like a trope
right so i still have this like
atheistic skeptical
you know kind of like eye roll
to spirituality
you know person in me i'm still that
person right so like yeah yeah heal
yourself do it yourself no one can heal
you like there's still some part of me
that's like okay whatever this sucks and
how does it how do i keep it from
sucking right like whatever my
experience of illness is
but the the the shift is really around
fear right so are you afraid of your own
body if you're afraid of your own body
that your own body is going to cause you
pain suffering and maybe even death
then you are living in this schism
right like you and your body are somehow
at war which is literally what we've
been conditioned around think about even
the semantics of our medications
antibiotics which literally
etymologically means against life okay
antibiotics anti-hypertensives
antidepressants we are enculturated
around warfare with the self because if
we fight ourselves of course it's a
losing battle an endless battle then we
will never recognize who the true enemy
of illusion is
right and so it's again it fits very
seamlessly into a model that would keep
us enslaved
and so the shift has to come from
understanding that symptoms are you
telling you
about you
that's all they are they are
informational translation some may say
even you know from the soul to the mind
to the awareness
right and so if i have a runny nose or
pain in my elbow
or you know my hair starts falling out
my reflexive response is curiosity it's
not fear and that fix it dominate it
make it go away you know sort of energy
that we've been uh reflexively
conditioned around
my first response and so many you know
i'm sure yours at this point too is
what is this about interesting right
there's something that i'm supposed to
get from this you know either i'm
supposed to end my relationship or i'm
supposed to change my breakfast or maybe
i'm supposed to look into that smoke
stack down the street you know or that
5g tower or whatever and there's
something here that my body is telling
me is out of alignment the body wants to
heal that's why in the space of a year
you can put
you know a devastating chronic illness
into full and lasting permission you
know i had the great privilege of
working with my mentor dr nicholas
gonzalez for the last year of his life
and he for 27 years
implemented a lifestyle protocol that
was primarily nutritional
to put
terminal
stage four metastatic cancers in
patients who are otherwise left for dead
by the system literally
into not just one or two or three or
five years of remission but decades
remission
right and i think that the fuel to the
fire of his practice was his passionate
belief
that the body does not make mistakes
and once you can connect to that without
exception right so i don't even
conceptualize like autoimmune illnesses
as the body attacking itself right so
the the immune system is a whole we
could have a whole you know hour on that
right like all the lies we've been told
about the immune system and what it is
and it's these soldiers fighting you
know this dangerous invisible demon
enemies whatever
the
the language that we use is important
right so if we say you know the body's
attacking itself or you know an allergy
is like a misunderstanding of like you
know something benign or whatever
we still kind of get this this
relationship uh being born you know to
the body that says oh silly body you're
messing up again
and if you can get to a place where you
understand that without understanding
the details the body's wisdom far
surpasses your conscious awareness
and that the invitation
is to develop that conscious awareness
to learn and you will you will it will
become clear right to you what your body
is trying to tell you which again can
range from the psychospiritual to the
very gross physical right so like you're
b12 deficient oh you know um all the way
to the fact that you know you you really
need to start talking about your
childhood sexual abuse
you're going to know you know what this
is about and often it's multi-layered
right but you won't know unless your
your channel and connection to your your
intuition
is
intact
and in my experience that didn't even
begin
uh to come online until i cleared the
sleep right because if you have brain
fog and bloating and
joint pain and you're not sleeping and
your energy's in the tank whatever
the
sort of like ritualized self-care of
looking at what you're eating
looking at what your you know or your
water is looking at your air looking at
your bedtime routine you know looking at
the very basics of all these your
products
all these decisions you have to make
every single day
and beginning to bring the awareness
that you have many choices and how do
you want to deliberately make a choice
that is empowering you right so you
start to activate that neurobiology of
personal empowerment and regeneration
and shift out of fight or flight
survival mode which we are invariably
going to be in when we are living in the
consciousness of the dominant orthodoxy
which says everything is random
protect yourself best you can
take our help
around how to stay safe
and do your best until you die
right
try to stay afloat until you until you
drown right so of course we're going to
be in fight or flight and so you you
shift out of that
through simply looking at the power of
your choice in your everyday decisions
and that's you know i've had a program
for many years that is simply predicated
on that right how do i
empower myself clear the slate of my
symptoms that are just kind of trying to
pull on my skirt and say come on enough
already like take the wheel of your own
damn car
and begin to really start to get that um
that sense of connection to intuition
back online because you know there's
homeopathy there's shamanism and plant
medicine you know there's essential oils
there's all types of you know
trauma-related um
interventions there's so many different
healing modalities available how do you
know what's for you it's so overwhelming
yeah and then you've got to take this
one's word for it and maybe read that
blog but this blog says something
different and yeah that is not the way
the way is to understand how your body
becomes an instrument of your own
decision making right and and you will
feel what a yes feels like in your body
you will feel what a no feels like which
is not what you think right it's not the
reactive no of like oh hell no no it's
not like that it's a neutral uncharged
quiet
not for me that's not the way and this
yes no in your body becomes available to
you when you start to
foreground
your self-care you know when i was in
medical school i was taught as is every
conventional doctor
that
nothing in your environment matters
right that's the one gene leads to one
illness that requires one pill or maybe
ten you know model
nothing
that you're drinking or eating or
thinking you know or your partnership
not it doesn't matter it's like it's so
trite and silly to even worry about
those things they don't matter
so
of course
we think yeah yeah of course it's nice
to eat healthy and maybe go for a jog
once in a while but when you're sick
you're sick right
when you have heart disease you have
heart disease you've got to deal with
that don't be reckless and irresponsible
imagine you have to take
the appropriate medication for that so
to learn that not only do these things
matter but they are the only way to
actually resolve chronic illness which
conventional medicine has never
purported to do for one patient ever in
the history of medicine it doesn't even
claim that
it's not that's not on offer
right so in order to access this concept
of working with the body to
come into greater alignment you know so
you're you're more vital healthier you
know and rejuvenated as you age you know
than than when you were you know 22 and
didn't know what the hell was going on
you must look at all of these choices
and you must start to decondition
you know that that brainwashing
i agree
that's fantastic
okay
why are you banned everywhere my youtube
is already demonetized so i don't have
any like
huge concerns
about
hosting people who have been like
de-platformed multiple times but what's
the excuse like i put it up on instagram
if you look at your wikipedia the first
sentence is i don't know something about
pseudoscience or something so like what
have you been d platformed off of and
are you given any reason and what are
you doing about it
yeah so
it's kind of you know it's kind of
logical you know when a mind of your own
my first book um was censored i remember
being on a call with the whole team at
harper collins and the publicist started
literally crying
because they had never experienced this
before
and
you know i don't know that they've ever
had
a picture of an exploding pharma pill on
the cover of a book written by an md
before so that might have been you know
the novelty there but i knew that this
was coming i knew that i wasn't going to
be invited to the dr oz show or the
today show or 60 minutes and all the
things that they waltz their you know
kind of premier authors onto i already
knew that was going to happen
because these are 70 pharma subsidized
outlets the illusion that media
including free media right so there's a
heavily circulated phrase at this point
right if it's free you're the product
the illusion that this is somehow
about information sharing as opposed to
mind control and manipulation of the
population it just means you haven't
researched you don't know who somebody
like edward bernice is you don't
understand the concept of propaganda and
you certainly don't understand the
concept of funding right and the
tethering and capture and control
although it's about more than money
of these entities
by
you know whatever you want to call them
the elite the controllers you know
okay okay wait pause who would these
people be this is where i get lost
because i am under the assumption that
people are like you when you went to
medical school
especially doctors they go in
the majority not all of them you get the
evil nurse that just likes to hurt
people from from time to time but they
go into medical school and they're
trying to help people and then they're
taught
certain things that are wrong but
they're taught it in such a logical way
that it doesn't really make sense to
question it and then they're just trying
to help people forever even though
they're not so who who would the people
at the top be
yeah i assume it's just stupidity
no it's intentional in my opinion and
it's malevolent and actually you know um
rudolph steiner uh talks about
if you've heard of him
uh
philosopher and
visionary and he created the waldorf
school program and a branch of medicine
called anthroposophy that is very
similar it's kind of spiritual medicine
the way that i practice and other things
and you know he talks about forms of
evil
right and it's so different than we
might imagine right the caricature of
like the bad sadist you were saying
right
um
and he talks about something called
luciferianism right or luciferic
energies
and if i describe it to you you're gonna
be pretty surprised because
as i was
you'll recognize it in almost every
public facing you know popular spiritual
guru
out there
right because this concept is that we
need to transcend the body we are all
one
and we are not separate
and when we transcend the body right
whether that's through something like
plant medicine or meditation
then we come into contact with the real
self with god and we are each god
right
and so this energy of spirituality
doesn't care about the body
right and so if you you know if you
take a vaccine or you take a pill
you just do a little meditation burn
some sage and say a mantra
it's good it's good you bless your meds
you know that kind of thinking it's very
prominent right now uh and
when we neglect
the other pole right which is the
three-dimensional materialism the fact
that we actually are incarnated in these
bodies there is cause and effect
that's a thing right
then we're out of balance right and the
other arm is is the reductionist concept
that we're just flush robots with gears
and buttons and you know we're prone to
breaking down and you know we're
floating on a dead rock in the middle of
nowhere
until we die and this is very dominant
in the scientism sort of the public
facing scientism uh consciousness that
you know when i do you know that
psychiatrist means doctor of the soul
that's the etymology of it right of
course i psych yeah yeah exactly right
i've never thought of that before yeah i
didn't until recently either and and i
never heard the word soul if i had heard
it i would have rolled my eyes at it but
i never heard the word soul my entire
training not one time it wasn't about
that it was about managing chemicals
that's what a psychiatrist is they
manage chemicals right and so
when these two poles are out of balance
very very dark
energies you know can manifest harm
abuse injury and all manner of
disconnection from
you know
what really is the truth which is that
we are embodied in a sacred vessel
it's it's both yes we're in a body and
yes it is a sacred temple and yes we are
divine right it's both it's both those
poles so when you know
when you think about right because i
have you know friends of course and um
ex-husbands and because well just one
things like that you know who are like
oh come on like yeah really everyone is
in the dark about this agenda and
they're all keeping a secret that's
really likely
no that's not how it works it's a
pyramid scheme
right so any any pyramid scheme
whether it's freemasonry or you know
multi-level marketing or scientology or
whatever
they
have a few people at the top
who know what's up
and who have a plan
that plan can relate to genocide
depopulation
uh you know it can relate to different
kinds of occultist religious beliefs
spiritual
you know sort of orientation whatever
they have a plan
and nobody
beneath the tip
of that you know space pyramidal space
knows what the hell is going on
and that's by design right so as you get
lower and lower down the rungs and you
have people like me in medical school
just trying to be a good girl right at
the bottom
implementing uh and instituting
many of these um
many elements of the agenda
you know
in disguise
right so for example in disguise
when you look at something like
circumcision
or even like the pap smear right or and
modern gynecology
when you look at you know medicalized
birth
there is so much
occultist energy in these things
let's just take a circumcision right
that is an occultist
ritual and the implications of that not
only for
obviously that ritually abused child and
i participated in these as a medical
student
but also for the mother
and for the partner are so legion and
they reverberate throughout our entire
lives
that they can only be obfuscated and
obscured by the assertion that it's
medically necessary so this is how and
why they turn
religious beliefs into
you know the secular objective
you know sort of realm of scientific
beliefs they're hiding it's all about
illusion and games that's why everything
is actually declared somewhere right so
you know you know the rockefeller agenda
for example it's
been written out since 2010. it's on the
internet you can read what's going on
exactly what's happening now
you know event 201 from october of you
know a year plus a go
the videos are online
right they they it's part of the game
they want us to know and they want us to
experience the cognitive dissonance that
comes from
wait what is this about is this really
about what we're being told it's about
or is it about something else is there a
story behind the story and then to
suppress
that intuition
that's a part of the machinery of the
game is that we have to consent to
participating in the illusion
and suppress our own intuition that it's
something different
and that's you know
easy to do because we've all been
traumatized and we want to trust that
there is a protector that there is
someone safe that we can trust and there
is an authority figure that would never
you know the fda is going to participate
in
you know uh
protection of serial felons also known
as you know pfizer johnson johnson and
astrazeneca of course not that's
ridiculous so many people would have to
be involved right and so you go to nasa
it's the same story all of these
entities
are riding on
the
the seat of doubt you know that it could
ever be possible
that this large scale a deception could
take root and it does because we each
choose to trust
that these authorities have our best
interests at heart and that such a thing
could never happen taxes i mean it's the
same story over and over and over again
in every single realm education
uh and you know the rockefellers have a
lot to do with it but they're not of
course the only one there some say
they're like 13 influential families and
bloodlines that are contributing some
people have you know other attributions
you know to other entities and
yeah
uh you know other forces let's say i
don't know i don't think anybody really
knows
but what you need to know is that you
have to source your own information
and you have to begin to come into
contact with how it is that you identify
your truth and how it is that you turn
over every stone because you know what
if you go get uh
you know a test let's say to
to see whether or not you are virally
contaminated
do you have any idea what that test is
like do you know what it's testing
have you looked into it
right and of course no is the answer for
most people because they say oh well i
don't know how to interpret science the
scientists figured it out and obviously
i'm gonna just do what the scientists do
because i'm not an expert
but now we're being invited each of us
to access our inner expertise because
guess what you are the only expert of
you no one no one no one no one on the
planet knows what's best for you other
than you defer to no one including me
defer to no one and that doesn't mean
you can't kind of get a sparked
inspiration or interest to go down a
rabbit hole from someone
or confirmation or validation of your
intuition which is honestly all that
i've ever offered anyone since the
beginning of my career as an activist is
really like confirmation that they're
not crazy
right no you're actually not crazy and
you you are right you know that
there is a better way or nothing's ever
wrong with you or your meds we're making
you sick right because we were trained
in in psychiatry when patients would
discontinue medication which was
normally like a week and a half long
process
uh and then of course they would get all
of these uh reap
sort of relapse symptoms
yeah i've heard right exactly yeah
you've heard that before right and we
were convinced uh
really convinced but also um
coerced to tell our patients that this
is evidence of their mental illness
and
obviously justification for them to
restart the medication you see
you were a bad patient and now you must
be punished by going back on your meds
forever you never get to stop them again
yeah and it wasn't until really 2014
that i started to see literature mostly
fava papa's group um published
that was asserting medically
scientifically that this has nothing to
do with relapse that and it's not a
so-called discontinuation syndrome
either this is withdrawal and it's
withdrawal on the order of opiates and
of course in my opinion it's actually
far more extreme as you know way more in
my opinion way more i went through
opiate withdrawal and ssri withdrawal
and opiate withdrawal was bad for about
six weeks
and i could feel like the effects for a
couple of years after just cognitively
but ssri withdrawal made me hallucinate
and it took two and a half years to go
away and i ended up on a zero carb diet
because
i was like
hallucinating like not even in the same
magnitude
and that was ssris that wasn't even what
my dad experienced with benzodiazepines
which was worse like which was yeah that
is the worst i mean i remember when i
was in in training at bellevue in new
york city uh
i was working in the icu because as an
intern you know you kind of rotate
around different
areas of the hospital and i was looking
in the icu and i had a patient who has
just admitted who had had a grand mal
seizure
in the parking lot of cvs
going to fill his xanax
prescription and even then
i was not in a position to question
anything right and was very much a
believer and even then i was like
hmm
this doesn't seem
right is this really helping this dude
and of course now there are you know
millions of people the world over you
know your dad included who can tell the
story that there are few challenges in
life and i actually think that the
people who are um
somehow create the conditions to
experience psychotropic withdrawal
are very special individuals right
because
to move through those spaces
uh to move through those spaces is a
self-initiation right so remember we
were talking about the dark knight of
the soul and all of the elements of of
ego death uh that are involved in that
and surrender
you know to faith and trust um that
there's something in this life for you
that's more than what you can feel or
see
in that in those moments of great
darkness
and we need those people who are
initiated to their power who are free
thinking
uh to help guide us now and i've said
you know many times that i believe that
those who are medicated uh
psychiatrically and diagnosed are the
canaries in the coal mine
so they are rightly sensitive to what is
wrong with the world and they're being
told that something is wrong with them
and you know i often reference a
krishnamurti quote that says it's no
sign of health to be well adapted to a
profoundly sick society
right so if you have a panic attack when
you go into a hospital yeah you could
say oh wow something's really wrong with
me that's crazy why would i be so
hyper-reactive or as your dad said you
could say that's totally appropriate you
know given um you know where you've come
from and of course you can still get to
a place where
that setting has no power over you right
yeah but that's a journey that's a
journey of self-reclamation and it
begins with appreciating that your
sensitivity and your so-called symptoms
and specifically so-called psychiatric
symptoms
actually come from the seat of your
perceptive power which is your
sensitivity right and if we don't
understand this or we don't understand
that it has to come with personal
responsibility and resolution of
victimhood those kind of all have to
come together um
or you will be
operationalized and leveraged by the
system empaths so-called empaths right
these sensitive folks they are the foot
soldiers of the current agenda
though these are the people who say you
know
wear a mask for your grandmother right
because it's so intolerable to them to
to deal with this level of distress or
the the possibility that they could be
on the bad side the wrong side the
selfish side
of history that they become you know the
virtue signaling finger waggers
because they haven't understood that
what comes with their sensitivity is a
fierce dedication to personal
responsibility and resolution of
victimhood
right and that's what i've seen you know
with the patients um i've worked with
and and some of them including um ali
zak if you've heard of her work you know
who are on the public stage right now
you know sounding the alarm
uh have come into their power that was
once labeled their mental illness
because of an understanding of that
personal responsibility and the
resolution of this no fair it's not my
fault it's your fault you know kind of
energy
i can totally see why you're censored
i didn't know at least he was your
censor that was good that was great
i'm a bit more yeah of a controlled up
at this point on some level right
because i i still have an instagram
account even though it's largely um i
think there's like five people who can
see anything i post yeah and you can't
comment and you can't swipe up or
whatever it's funny um i was the
platformed off of facebook and the
the truth is that they kind of probably
want to keep an eye on me right and
there are some like kind of
you know
trolls whatever you want to call them
who are seemingly obsessed with me like
it's very adolescent energy like
constantly writing these extensive blogs
like studying my dynamics in my marital
relationship and where i'm going in my
dance videos and it's just like wow so
much of their time you know
is devoted to thinking about me it's
kind of amazing right because there's a
lot of um so-called astro turfing it's
all all bots right like it's all
digitized and there's no real humans
it's just generating the perception that
there is a an organic movement against
someone or something or some concept but
then there's like actually some human
beings involved who are you know working
for the system and whether or not they
you know know what they're doing who
will never know but i think it makes
total sense you know like why should i
be able to
play in facebook's sandbox according to
my rules of of you know freedom
well you could say well we have
constitutional entitlement to free
speech yes and you know that would
assume that the constitution is what we
think it is and that it's being
protected in the ways that we think it
is which i don't actually believe so
it's a it's a whole another kind of a
bloodless war you know that that we're
at right now and i think it's i think
it's fine you know this stuff doesn't
get to me at all for whatever reason i'm
just kind of wired this way to not not
care and to think it's kind of fun and
plus i believe in bucky fuller's quote
you know where you don't fight the
existing system you know you create a
new one that renders it obsolete and i
know that we have to create a new system
and i know that we have to revoke
consent it's why i got off my smartphone
last year because i know that my
smartphone is my first line of consent
to every aspect of the
agenda maybe even the transhumanistic ai
agenda that's being rolled out right so
if i don't like that then how about i
revoke consent through my behavior and i
look at whether i want to actually be
buying on amazon and i look at you know
whether i have not that i have stocks
but other stocks and you know certain
companies that i'm actually then
publicly condemning and fighting so
becoming coherent around our energy and
effort is something that we're actually
being invited towards so i don't
i don't actually think it's particularly
problematic although my husband um
does you know he spends a lot of time
you know trying to um
expose the the unjust elements of you
know what's happening and the fact that
we're being targeted and sometimes even
you know threatened and and all the rest
but this has been going on for a long
time for me you know i had aerial
pictures of my home uh when i was up
north you know with death threats
because of a blog i wrote on homebirth
imagine
really i had a blog i wrote a blog on
homeworth i gave birth to my daughter at
home because i was like
[ __ ] no am i going into one of those
places
like you're gonna
yeah no thank you
exactly horrible lights with a beeping
attached machines to you and then
no thank you but but you can imagine
right like if you empower women to
understand
that birth is
their experience of self-initiation it's
their entitlement
and that they don't need daddy medicine
to manage their body for them all of the
dangers when the body does it wrong
and then to take the baby away and clean
that dirty baby and vaccinate that you
know broken
you know immune system and blah blah
blah all the rest
if
it's like think about the ritual
uh power of that
and when you get a mom
in that level of conditioning which of
course is amplified by all of the
emotions and all of that inner
pharmacopoeia of what's happening then
into the fold at that point you have her
for life not just her her child right so
that's why home birth is it's probably
my number one advocacy even though i
focus mostly on you know psychiatry but
it's the one that i feel so passionately
about because and i've i've probably you
know inspired i don't know what dozens
of my friends because it's like i will
not shut up about this i will not say oh
i understand do the best you can like no
this it happens one time per life you
know that you bring forward and it is
it is something that every woman is
capable of and if we can only
you know sort of uh decondition
ourselves and wake up in time because
you don't get a do-over on that right
but of course i understand you know why
it garnered that level of uh response
because remember i'm one of them
right i have that credential
um yeah you know and from a fancy place
carrier that's a lot just different it's
because people are still enculturated to
to listen to somebody like me even
though i'm saying the same thing as so
many others you know uh including
non-clinicians and and natural um
clinicians and chinese medicine
practitioners all the rest but because
i'm from the priesthood you know people
are more willing to
to listen to me and that's potentially
why i'm
more dangerous and so you know the
character assassination is kind of the
only way they can get at uh calling me
reckless or dangerous or whatever get at
the undermining but honestly most of the
criticisms that i received they're
actually true
you know what i mean like no one's like
out there lying which i find interesting
because they could for the most i mean
i'm sure there are exceptions
but that's also been helpful to me you
know because
you know if if someone calls me a cult
leader for example
can i look at how i am a cult leader
right
i don't know maybe maybe there's
something in there you know so it hasn't
really had the desired effect of
intimidating me shutting me up or
otherwise marginalizing me either you
know because my first book made the
the list of the hallowed you know sort
of um
brotherhood itself the new york times
right how weird is that after being
censored by all of these outlets that's
weird that's weird yeah that's
definitely it's like a wild game
okay
that was fascinating
uh this is so fun i'm so glad you came
on i was a little bit worried because i
saw that you'd stopped using a
smartphone and i was like how
how do i get in touch with this human
being and get her on here i still have a
computer
yeah there are other ways there are
other better ways yeah it's it's
marginally better it's actually been i
prepared for like three months i mean i
wrote a whole like ebook about it and
everything else
and honestly it was so much easier than
i imagined i mean i was at a point where
i was feeling a lot of shame actually uh
as a mom you know being on this device
that i was telling my kids not to be on
and not it's not like i was like messing
around on my phone like on a dating app
or something i was working always
working working yeah trying to get rid
of a couple emails whatever and i'd be
like kind of hiding around the corner of
the wall
you know like trying to get it done or
i'd be like always like i can't remember
the last time i went to the bathroom
without my smartphone or did my laundry
without my smartphone or you know it's
just it was um
i was like it's [ __ ] you know and i
went on a silent retreat actually in
march of last year
and i came back and i was like you know
i'm done
i'm done i'm gonna at least try to
regulate myself which never work
and try to do like the harm
you know sort of uh
reduction model of you know i only give
myself a few hours later or something
like that yeah yeah that that didn't
work and not only that but then i
stepped into the pandemic and and
started to research
18 hours a day or something for months
and months and months but yeah you know
confirming my intuition about what's
going on
and uh and then i just knew you know
that
it was time and it was so much easier so
much easier than i thought i can't
recommend it enough i mean i have like a
hipster flip phone now which is called a
light phone
and uh i do my work on my computer so
much more efficiently and then i get up
yeah and i go live my damn life you know
so it's it is it does feel like a
reclamation and i feel
proud you know i feel proud of myself um
and i hope that you know others others
will consider and i know they will
because i started a telegram group you
know just to kind of learn a bit about
how to do this what about all these apps
and what do i do with this and
in 12 hours there were 1600 people in
the group i thought one
well post on instagram
seems like something people are thinking
about right is getting off these
devices yeah and a lot of these apps
that you use for work or to communicate
with other people are
easy to put on your laptop
whatsapp telegram signal like those are
all on on your laptop and you type
faster it makes sense i'm gonna get
there eventually because i have such
a work for you know
like 18 hours like just constantly and
then if i go i'll go lay in the sun but
i have my smartphone so that i can be
productive at the same time as getting
some sun so uh
yeah totally it fits into that that um
wound right that like we have to always
be
useful
um
to always be
accessible that was a big one for me
like if i don't respond in time
i'm going to lose some of that value you
know to people and i'm going to lose
that aspect of my personality and
identity that is that kelly's responsive
and
available you know communicative i don't
know so whenever you know things like
this are scary it's because they
challenge some of that illusory identity
that we've been writing you know that
that mask you know unintended that we've
been wearing that
it has to fall at some point right we
have to understand that you know if if
we are the person who's always on time
well we're also the person who's late
sometimes right if we're the person
who's the intellectual well we also
say stupid things you know or like you
know how do we have both how do we own
it all and it's only through not
attaching to
any given identity
uh with too much rigidity that we can
try to understand like what our
essential core is
you know and what are the values of that
essential core i've become very
interested in morals and values you know
um
as the true guiding
principles and forces in in our lives
and
you know for me one of them is freedom
and
that is more important than any aspect
of my personality that i might have to
shift or change you know i used to hate
cats two years ago now i have two cats
and they're like deities in my household
i'm kind of comfortable with that kind
of thing you know like being totally
wrong thought meds were good not so much
okay
i think i think the only way to to heal
is to be okay with being wrong and i've
also found because i i was
i thought the medical system was there i
thought it had been helping me and
saving me and i was told i was broken
from the age of like five or four before
i can remember that this is you and
you're broke and it's not your fault and
i think that's what made me so angry
that i when it was like oh wait there's
something i can do about this it was
like you took all my power away by
telling me that i was broken and that
there was nothing i could do about it
like how dare you and you're doing that
to other people
like how dare you take that power away
from people so that's that's kind of
where i'm
i'm operating for from i don't know
where i was going with that but i have
one more question for you
that i that i want to get to um which is
i like i've seen that you do dance how
old are you
this this wasn't the question but out of
curiosity i'm gonna be 43 and uh
okay so you look amazing you're
completely full of life right so what
are some like quick suggestions you can
give people that that you've learned
like like i said i saw that you dance
like how much do you sleep like
what does your diet look like vaguely
like just yeah easy things
oh yeah i got a lot of these um
and you know i'm a big believer in
in the
reset right my kind of reset um
not the great reset where you you
control for a lot of variables all at
once for something like a month right so
that's what my program has been and i
also recognize that's like a barrier to
entry for a lot of people who don't want
to take that kind of a deep dive and who
just want to kind of like dip a toe in
or whatever and so that's what we've
done
uh sarah and i have a membership called
final life project where it's like
literally we
like for one week in a month everyone
goes to bed or who wants to at 9pm
that's a big one for me all right
because i my entire life changed when i
started to go to bed early and early is
like i get ready for bed at 8 30.
and so if i'm meeting a girlfriend for
dinner or whatever
it's like a six o'clock reservation
and i'm in i live in miami and i have
most of my friends are um latin
and you know from south america from
mexico or whatever and the concept of
eating a dinner at six for them is like
that's like lunch right so i don't care
you want to hang out with me that's how
it is so these sort of um
priorities are something that and then
everybody gets to know right like my
kids know i meditate every morning
and they i've been doing that for years
and years now so they just know they
don't bother me they wouldn't actually
never even imagine that they
could bother me like just don't go there
like she's doing her thing
and this is how you know so many women
who have you know
kids are
still exercising that that kind of
narcissistic extension psychology that
we were raised with which says you know
i have to tend to my child so that my
child you know reflects well upon me and
i can feel good about myself
right it's not the way
the way is you come first you come first
always without exception right in fact i
had an experience where um recently
where my youngest daughter was having
she's an empath for sure and she was
having this like inexplicable anxiety
right and we in miami we have friends
who run an ecstatic dance thing you know
event uh every month
this is like it's church for me right
especially the daytime one on a sunday
and i missed it
because i was working with her right
like on this that's i think the only
time in 12 years of my mothering that
i've actually had that experience of
sacrificing like that i just don't do it
i put my
needs first and whether that's
meditating in the morning i move
probably six days a week and my
preferences is dance
and i wouldn't imagine
canceling that because of anything like
it's just not even a concept in my world
it comes first and it comes first before
work um and and that
was a shift that happened recently for
me maybe three years ago when i moved
here so it's not like i've always been
this way but my entire nervous system
has changed because of prioritize
prioritizing something that brings me
that kind of joy versus something that
feeds my defensive ego that says i'm
producing you know um and helping or
serving or whatever it is
and i am
very very very strict
about certain aspects of my diet because
i heal myself as you know right like you
don't even want to mess around
necessarily and that's not to say i
don't have like intuitive flux in my
diet
but i never ever ever consume
gmos gluten
dairy or processed sugar
and
i don't know that's just
so i if i go to a friend's house and
that's all they got i won't eat and it's
cool it's not like a big drama you know
it's just it's fine
um
and i also am
extremely vigilant about conflicts in my
life so wherever i feel that energy of
conflict whether it's with a friend or
you know a family member or
a colleague
um
that becomes foregrounded in my
consciousness as something i need to
address and something i need to look
into myself to see how i'm contributing
to it and what kind of responsibility i
can take
so that we can seek harmony and
resolution because otherwise those
people hold
elements of your power through
projection
right condemnation judgment
and i need all of my all of my power
here centralized um
you know but i i have been in the past
couple of years since moving to miami
from new york really
in a process of
orienting you know around a different
set of priorities and new york is very
um as most people know
um very much feeds that masculine
impulse you know towards
uh productivity and
um
really a kind of relationship to time
uh as something
you know to kind of like it's like a
scarcity mentality i guess versus an
abundant mentality that says like
i'm here now you know where do i gotta
be you know i don't have to be anywhere
you know that which is so much more the
culture down here was shocking to me
when i moved here it took like six
months for me to adjust you know to
people don't use email they don't show
up they show up hour late you know or
it's just a whole different uh culture
which actually was very healing for me
in resolving
um rigidity but i would say anybody who
wants to
take a step towards
this process
uh change your breakfast
that's that's normally what i
i suggest you know change your breakfast
so that
at least it's you know free of those
things i mentioned
your gluten dairy sugar
gmo free and see what happens right
because even that little teeny teeny
commitment
begins to disrupt
the
belief system that none of it matters
and that this is kind of how it's going
to be for you
and all it is is a choice you know in my
in my protocol if i don't mind reset
there's no supplements at all
why not because supplements are not
wonderful all right i'm sure they are
and have helped many many people uh in
fact sayer's entire database you know
greenman info indexes tens of thousands
of primary
uh literature studies that suggest that
they're actually more helpful you know
than medications however
there is an experience of i need this
because something in me is missing
that i think it's very psychologically
important to disrupt and so when we just
look at the choices that we make every
day sleep eating contemplation you know
the products do i buy this detergent or
that detergent
then you begin to see
i'm the one
driving the car
oh
okay i thought it was the passenger
interesting and that has a cascade of
effects that also i think correlates to
um
like i said in your own biology that
affords us the capacity to regenerate
and to heal
from things that we've been told we
might suffer from for life
that was
epic
thank you so much for coming on um if
people are trying to find you or want to
find your books
what are they called and where can they
find you
cool so i am at
kellybroganmd.com and there's a ton ton
of free information there
i've been blogging highly referenced
blogs for many years now
um
and
the
uh
best way to stay in touch with me is
through my newsletter because who knows
right now i'm on telegram uh i have a
telegram channel
and so far so good but who knows right
it's like i call it the census
censorship shuffle like we don't know we
gotta be nimble uh so that's why the
newsletter is the better the better bet
and yeah mind of your own own yourself
and then i have a kids book that i wrote
with my daughter called a time for rain
that i'm really proud of actually and
those are all
at the moment uh at barnes noble and
amazon
thank you very much for coming on that
was that was fascinating it's a total
pleasure
[Music]
you